hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the killings and altstadt
okay we just got old out of a sewer I
got scared
I got scared by this lantern here and
now we're gonna go back in or out I
don't know where the other door went and
you know what I don't rightly care I'll
probably have to go back that this is
fancy
no I don't recall coming into this
castle at all so I don't remember being
here excuse me there's something I need
to smash I'm done the key oh no no it
couldn't be that easy
boxes hiding secrets no something under
the stairs Oh
haunted box oh wow that box is stuck
forever through thalers 25 my baby there
doesn't seem to be a door in this
entrance hall and that looks really
weird
the design of this castle seems to be
shoddy I'm an engineer I know what I'm
talking about kinda I was also a
carpenter for two years the more you
know
statues my favorite okay both that was
castle where am I going
[Music]
what a deal what the good deal what the
good deal wow you're really need those
things don't you okay so this must be
the castle hub oh man how long is this
custom story hello oh oh no okay nothing
nothing yet
hey that was a whole lot of nothing this
guy puts a lot of just not useless
scares but scares where if you didn't go
in the room nothing would have happened
like that's gonna happen in here okay
I'm very apprehensive right now man this
is just a hub this is one of three
hallways then expect that
you
the music
[Music]
[Applause]
so far so nothing I kind of wish you'd
go away now it does really kind of
destroy the atmosphere tell you what I'm
gonna save and exit and then I'll come
back in hopefully the we just got live
with it I guess to the next area
[Music]
okay now what's the point of this room
anything nothing just gonna break all
yours off okay
[Music]
Oh God
shut up make it stop make it stop whoa
[Music]
I had such good memories and I don't
want to live anymore
[Music]
you
I may just turn the sound down
Oh God more books more hahaha
books and Zelda music shop music o open
I can't do it anymore
okay I have officially cranked down the
side the sound for you guys blissful no
I won't I did not I didn't do that in
the future I don't know what it was
there might be more than three but I
don't know oh there's the last one not
the last one can me kidding me right
[Music]
stop I pulled all the books there are no
more there's no more there's no more I
can't even get down there yes I can and
I can't it's invisible walls this is how
I died
[Music]
you
[Applause]
I can't do it myself
[Music]
but no I kind of like it now I want to
keep going oh well it goes Brown myself
in a bathtub
oh I gotta go I gotta go so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for videos that I've done and
as always I'll see you in the next video
Oh
[Music]